look I read I am I put so much sunscreen
I can't believe it
we're going to watch the sunset it's
gonna set soon - is getting ready
I don't think we'll make it but we'll
say hey welcome to Santorini
does that first stay here and we're
gonna go get some lunch it's so hot
I'm dying I'm dead I'm legally dead
we got traditional Greek food see what's
good I have never seen any of this food
before this is my jam I love this song
it's my favorite you want to take a
picture like this or like this this okay
then okay no problem I think she thought
I was a photographer she's gonna be so
disappointed we should see the pictures
what are you gonna get
that was his boss on it nothing Ghazi
Juke soup do [ __ ] how much is this
while the earth
[Music]
I love centering your calendars what it
wait I like the Dolphins they're growing
it out oh my god the view I have to film
the view the public back it's so high I
can't very nice
I ran I ran back so today it's me and
Marcia's anniversary
four years
we're gonna have dinner I need to find
my staff I need to show her okay I'm
coming
oh my God look at my Greek goddess woman
yes oh hey look at Ren I am don't look
red how did this happen I put so much
Sun cream so what would this audio so
basically we're saying at the end
Rooney's luxury hotel and in Santorini
and they knew who we were so they are
upgrading us to a new room that's
supposed to have like a cool cave and
that's really cool I'm very excited are
you excited brush
you heard the excitement for here first
hello friends you just had food
[Music]
thank you so much but and thumbs up for
the food I didn't throw fish the food
we're in the new suite oh my god I
bought ice cream and the guy was so
homophobic they thought I was gay and he
was like gay people I want to kill them
and I didn't realize because I didn't
hear what he said but I'm I realized
after and I wish I told that me was an
idiot I don't know it was weird I never
met anyone so I would like ignorant I
guess you could say but we have amazing
near room look at this wow it's so big
and oh my god I want to swim in this
this is a cave pool
do you like a it's amazing so this is
the end Ronis sweets
that they gave us for free so nice you
can't see anything
look at this okay we're gonna go in the
pool an amazing kipling cool this is it
boys I'm curious hotel ever ever say
that that's fine Marcia
there she is
might say is going through the kit see
your head
look how right I am I put so much
sunscreen I can't believe it
we're going to watch the sunset it's
gonna set soon my sis getting ready
I don't think we'll make it but we'll
say it wants to see the sunset he's
gonna see the sunset and we're not okay
so we gave up we didn't go to where
we're supposed to go but only thing is
finding so many people
it looks like the sunset is very
appreciated appreciated here I'll get
some better shot of it don't worry don't
worry
we did it we did it okay so happy
morning Annie next I can't wait to have
a dessert even in this line no oh god no
my mom is gonna be so upset cuz she
always like don't get burned I will kill
you this is the light mom I'm not I'm
not Brian I promise please very nice
[Music]
what's that do you want to get a
friendship bracelet I'm ready here we go
they're so excited for my feet feels
like I'm dipping it in like a soda like
I'm dipping it in soda look at they're
so like stuck on my feet very good again
everyone hey how are you right today
we're going on a selling boat
oh it's left already we got a hurry
there's our boat I think why not
okay we're at the red beach I am the red
man cuz I'm so burned where we're going
in the water for a swim it looks
beautiful
okay I'm so sunburned but let's swim
what you doing
I should not be sunbathing so this is
our final stop we're gonna eat and get
more sunburned because why not oh
there's somebody what it's like fine
yeah the more they're so clear it's so
beautiful it's really nice what is this
so creepy she's such a weirdo okay
we are back I don't look - oh my god
Jesus Christ and I have a lot of battery
it was a great day in the Sun there was
such a mess when we came back I didn't
want to film it but Jesus Christ it took
so long to get back oh yeah that's my
son torini vlog I hope you enjoyed
watching it or hanging out with me I
guess it's great and back to making
videos tomorrow this haircut is amazing
thank you so much I'm gonna end it on a
good note but I can't think of anything
just thanks for watching my videos
we gotta cool the room because of it so
that's good
alright alright brofist
[Music]